hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to what may be the last
episodes of five nights of [ __ ] boys
still kind of reeling from the fact that
I'm playing five nights [ __ ] boys and I
don't even know what the point of it
being about [ __ ] I just went outside I
talked to Danny I totally I also told
him those six yacht beeps it's time to
make it lucky number seven
so we've beat everybody and we've got
everyone's Limit Breaks which I don't
know if it was required to do this game
or beat the end boss but I have a
strategy to beat the end boss I'm gonna
hit all the hats first trying to
paralyze the middle one but I made just
for go paralyzing because it's almost
not worth it like of course it gives me
a little bit of an opportunity but
there's a lot of damage loss from foxy
just trying to flail he uselessly Adam
but either way cheers everybody who's
been following along who is legal to
follow along and thank you so much for
joining me for this journey I love you
guys so much
Oh
mmm Oh God okay so now we need to go
back to the left hallway or the right
hallway would be fine too I guess but
it's gonna go down this hallway oh my
goodness
and here we go this is a big one this is
the big one we got a beat goal in Freddy
fireteam I mean you're not a debauchee
I'm gonna get your dicks how does that
even work golden Freddy how do you
suppose it you're gonna do that okay
here we go all right got this we got
this do we got this we got this okay
well oh [ __ ] here we comes okay so top
hat toss on you oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not
doing [ __ ] god dammit oh [ __ ] I'm
already [ __ ] up I'd even not hit
golden Freddy first tits oh [ __ ]
bunny up I'm not doing well I'm not who
are you gonna put to sleep come on come
on
good he's awake we're okay we're okay
we're okay just don't kill anybody just
don't kill anybody
yes that's the what I like chica why
didn't you hit that one D you tried it
you never know it might happen
bunny hop on
please paralyze [ __ ] okay didn't work
nevermind then that one's gone okay that
one's gone okay we're doing good okay
that's okay
dammit wrong one I forgot that I wasn't
going to the right one okay so now I can
start hitting golden Freddy I'm gonna
try god I really want to try to paralyze
this [ __ ] paralyze please [ __ ]
duck
okay fine you wanna play it that way I
can play it that way
cuz I've got the skills baby you only
oh you're only fueling up my ability to
do my Limit Breaks
the top hat toss is golden Freddy plank
walk to golden Freddy
pizza pass to yourself you large pizza -
Freddy paralyzed please damn it goddamn
it
okay you scream at the Hat and you use a
cake on I gotta be oh no the puppet
timer isn't here okay so maybe they
expect this one to last a lot longer
than the other ones do why is that hats
still alive I didn't do it already just
scream at the Hat you know you use
birthday present on foxy and you use a
large pizza on Fox
of course you had Foxy of course it's
gonna force of course that doesn't that
doesn't help me at all that doesn't help
me at all
Freddie why is that hat still live
scream it's goddamn hat [ __ ] whatever
you know whatever we're gonna be fine no
no no no that's why I did two of them in
case he falls asleep god this is gonna
be a rough battle yeah he's asleep okay
why can I not make that hat go goddamn
away okay so what we're gonna do still
gonna be laying the smackdown on that
we're gonna get the hat out of the
goddamn way now you're foxy finally
goddamn gone okay Bonnie's gone that's
fine Bonnie was damaged anyway you give
that to foxy that's good okay you do
that
foxy you're gonna get Bonnie up and
you're gonna heal Bonnie as soon as e
gets up dammit okay well at least we got
the heal we got the resurrection in we
got the heal on Bonnie
so that means okay so Freddy is almost
as limit brick but not quite chicas just
about there so close we're gonna put a
medium soda on chica this is actually
really skilled which isn't very good and
Bonnie's gonna do the bonbon Cabo Cabo
baby you get Freddy all you want we know
who's the real damage dealer is gonna be
funny out bunny out bunny out buddy out
bunny out all bunny hops baby oh so many
bunny hops Oh
oh we got this in the bag
I probably should have thrown in some
backup passes in there but I'll take the
bunny ops because the bunny house
whoa they do a lot of damage come on you
so delicious okay I can't get ahead of
myself I have a seven shot Steve I've
been recording this is one long sequence
oh man oh God that's right that's right
that's right I got to other limit big
skip whoa [ __ ] what does that mean what
does that mean you what does that mean I
don't like that I don't like that I'm
gonna play defensively this round I
don't like that at all
oh [ __ ] well that's good I guess
cool what hell happened all right you
know what I'm gonna give everyone speed
because you never know whoa oh no wait
oh that's right Oh higher combo all
right combo yes please oh god the right
guy can't do the rush can I get but I
can definitely paralyze him skill Pizza
Pass foxy item chica okay scream plank
walk plank walk rushdown oh my god
rushed down yes absolutely
holy [ __ ] of course rush down
that's so much damage well how'd you do
now rest when it rush down end damn it
okay whatever I'm still doing fine do
that you speed cher you scream no you
skill he'll Bonnie you bunny up
we're almost there for two other Limit
Breaks we're good we're good
are you gonna put his like boxy that's
okay foxy already went
[Music]
[ __ ]
hahaha why did I need all that many
tokens
[Applause]
five nights later okay alright five
nights passed by of that screaming in my
ear did you finally get to the night at
a battery did you get laid that's what I
want to know did you get laid you did it
it was your night of debauchery wait can
I do anything
[Music]
[ __ ] what is that [ __ ] okay
so that was five nights at [ __ ] boys so
what happened here is I think I got
ahead of myself for the last one here
but either way I really hope you enjoyed
it I had the time of my life
it was so much fun for me like that's
ridiculously awesome I don't know you
guys not to be yet because I've been
recording in one lock sequence honesty
god I love that it was so much fun
okay so easy alright so easy oh there's
two more games that there's five nights
to [ __ ] boys to and I think five nights
to [ __ ] boys three is either the process
be made it's about to be made I'm a
little flat battery of the book bang out
a cig with me just let me know let me
know in the comments below if you want
me to play the other ones and if you
want me to play it
the same way that I played this one
if you do write in the comments below if
you don't write in the cops will I don't
know if you made it this far as a
super-huge enjoy the series very much
just like I did so if you didn't then
I'm sorry you came all this way for
nothing
but I had a great time with this you
know it's weird cuz when I first started
about five nights and [ __ ] boys I'm like
okay that possibly be any good but it
honestly enter hurt me plenty to access
that like say Allah so I couldn't have
done that anyway I've been probably a
secret on that put D be honest I really
don't want you really don't want to have
to drink more to be able to just get
through the night xxx so I'm sure
there's someone that's done it who was
not drunk
and it's probably competent at gaming
and talking about stuff so fine matin I
mean you'll be good so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
so much for being awesome thank you so
much for being here with me and thank
you for just generally what is going on
here what am I just how my just just
until the end of time here now let's
wait till see of everything no it
[ __ ] loops ffs song loop so I'm
assuming that's it so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for supporting me through all this
series and god this has been a lot of
fun it's been a while since I just
plowed through an entire series all in
one sitting but I have to admit hey the
liquid motivation kind of did help a lot
so drug minecraft is coming very soon I
am out it's gonna be a similar mix of
this but thank you again everybody so
much for watching you guys are amazing
and the greatest fan base I could
possibly hope for
I love you to death I'd have to say that
cuz I'm drunk you know I mean it because
I say when I'm sober
that's what love is right there so thank
you again everybody zilbert's watching
check out all the other five days of
Freddy's crap that I've done in the past
even the knockoff games in the
description below and days over there
thank you again everybody
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
okay
I [ __ ] I [ __ ] seven shots
[Music]